(bass guitar music)
- [Announcer] From Daytona
International Speedway,
this is the Motor Racing Network.
- This sport will break you if you let it.
(engines roaring)
I've noticed some faces, like
they're surprised to see me.
(air drill whirring)
Historically, NASCAR is Caucasian males.
(engine revving)
That's what people think of,
and that's what they see in the sport.
Nobody at the track looks like me.
(uplifting music)
My name is Brehanna Daniels,
and I am the first African-American
female pit crew member
for NASCAR.
I had no idea that that would happen,
that's not why I came into this sport,
but I made history.
I'm still in shock, to this day.
(metal tapping)
I was the only girl, but
that actually kind of gave me
some more motivation, you know,
to kick the guys' butts I
was goin' against (laughs).
(brakes squealing)
I have to work twice as
hard as the next man does.
It's like I already have like
two targets on my back:
I’m a female, I’m African-American.
But everything I get, I work for.
(blues music)
Pit stops usually range
between, like, 10 and 14 seconds.
(air drill whirring)
Everybody has to move quick.
(blues music)
There's a front tire changer,
a front tire carrier,
a rear tire carrier,
a gas man and a jack man.
And I am a rear tire changer.
(blues music)
We train year round 'cause you
have to have that strength.
This isn't just about car mechanics,
you have to be an athlete.
(blues music)
You know, we're really in charge
of hookin' that driver up
and makin' sure he's good to go.
Our pit stop has to be on point,
everybody has to come
together and work as one team
to send our driver off,
to have him in good hands.
(blues music)
- [Man] Good job.
(quiet uplifting music)
- My mission is to make
sure to be that face
for women of color and
little boys and little girls,
and I hope that, one day,
you know, when people
will think of NASCAR,
they see it as multiple
faces and not just one.
I want everybody to join this sport.
Come on (laughs)!
(engines roaring)
(quiet uplifting music)